[Music]
was he's a really interesting player
because prior to this year everyone
always said he was the best player to
never win anything in any game there are
names that transcend the titles the
highlights the moments names that defied
the odds and defined competition names
that will never be for God
Susie's name is already etched in the
league of legends history books he was a
mechanical genius in the game's early
days and was the first player to make
consecutive World Finals he was the
poster child for his country's eSports
scene the face of China's belief that it
could challenge Korea but he represented
something else - a silver medal for
years Suzy was known as perhaps the
greatest player to never win a title
domestically or internationally today
though Suzy is the face of a new
movement China doesn't need to believe
they can challenge Korea anymore they've
proven that they can in one year Suzy
has tasted victory
[Applause]
and he has slain Giants
she's chasing six
[Applause]
he's been humbled to six years after his
debut
hoozy is still the face of Chinese
League of Legends but he's also the face
of a champion this is his story
Jian Yu Zhi Zhi Hao made his competitive
league of Legends debut in October 2012
with royal club and rose to prominence
as a mechanically gifted
fifteen-year-old heading into the 2013
LPL spring split royal weren't quite
able to capitalize on the prowess of
their prodigy in the bot lane that split
belonged to oh my god who hoisted the
first trophy of the LPL era while royal
finished in fifth in 2013 the LPL summer
playoffs came after the world
championship
so before royal would get another shot
at a domestic title it was time to play
for a place on the world stage
this time they were able to defeat their
domestic rivals a vanquishing oMG in the
grand finals after dramatic run through
the losers bracket it was enough to
secure their spot into the world's
quarterfinals as China's number one seed
by this point royal had learned to
harness Ozzy's impressive potential in
the bottom lane so much so that their
primary strategy at the time was dubbed
raising the puppy you know a lot of
people may have heard about Suzy and
he's like he's a lot like faker he's a
very young prodigy and extremely fun to
watch and the whole strategy of royal is
built around what they call raising the
puppy it's a lot like protecting the
double lift except for and so you you
he's noticed the puppy in China because
of his youth royal were far from the
first team to consider playing around a
strong bottom lane carry but Ozzy was
good enough to make it work so heading
into a faded quarter-final against an
lmg roster that had terrorized the group
stage even taking a game off of Korean
powerhouse sk telecom t1 all eyes were
on Ozzy to be the difference
sorry there's a sign unites a newsie is
coming in from the right side surprise
here comes the babe kill for white
Samsung can't escape this one
they focused our Uzi but look at him
it's
[Applause]
this is going to be a win for Royal Club
they are going to take down their
Chinese rival two to zero
amazing performance to set the babe
to vote for them to handle this travel
around you can see exactly what it needs
the Royal their semi-final match would
be against a fanatic squad who looked
impressive in the tournament but despite
any advantages that fnatic appeared to
have on paper royal were too much for
the European squad will be up in one
second but it is Suzie cleaning up you
see white on the board twice Derek in a
death Busey comes up me the Royal is
going to be walking their way into the
base on this one
they have inhibitors in their eyes
they're gonna have Nexus turrets in
their eyes movement goes down Duty is
alive juicy is doing damage it's royal
Royall were one series away from the
summoner's Cup and for a 16 year old
Ozzie it was his chance to prove himself
against another young prodigy named
faker Royals impressive performance at
Worlds were enough to make many analysts
into believers SK Telecom t1 or Royal
Club Boyle all the way all right
doublelift I know you want to be on the
Korean hype train let's go tell your
coach I'm thinking about it thanks coach
no thanks I'm going to boil my brain
says SKT but I got that Chinese pride
I'm friends with table a well it's gonna
win I'm gonna have to go ahead to boil
as well
I like the underdogs here I feel like
they're gonna complete their raise the
puppy strategy and derail this hype
train but they were no match for SK
Telecom t1 K Baker and his surging
roster would bring home Korea's first
world championship while Ozzy and
China's hopes were sidelined SK Telecom
are just rolling through the Nexus
turrets are potentially going to go down
this could be a 20 minute game they will
Royall season shouldn't have been over
they still had a spot in the LPL
playoffs waiting for them at home they
had to forfeit both the semi-finals and
the third-place match after whites and
table a both retired leaving the org
without a roster
still it was a promising first year for
a young uz he put up strong domestic
showings cemented his place among the
very top of the game's greatest
mechanical talents and placed second at
the world championship he couldn't have
known that this would be the start of a
pattern royal made big changes in 2014
rebranding to star horn Royal Club and
rebuilding their roster around the star
player that had been at the center of so
much of their success so far Busey was
the only player to come back to the team
in 2014 but even more surprising was his
decision to move from bottom lane to mid
and as the team struggled to a
disappointing 6th place in the spring
regular season royal shuffled its roster
once again this time they brought in
Korean imports zero and the legendary in
Sec allowing Ozzy to return to his
rightful place in the bottom Lane this
roster worked far better for the team
and they placed third in the regular
season
that was enough for them to make it to
the regional finals where they did
manage to overcome oMG and qualify as
China second seed through the winter
side of the bracket
it was another chance for royal on the
world stage another chance to prove that
China was more than second fiddle in the
international league seen another chance
for Z to show off
three kill invites me to chop Busey goes
in for another one that's another a
simple royal patchouli the game after
making short work of their group stage
Royals quarterfinals opponents were
domestic rivals Edward gaming they
started off strong but using
intervention in that fight it's gonna be
easy up now get hit up that
who take the safety off then he grabbed
that CC after the bottom blade nominees
for us to run it looks like they want
the whole thing and he's in trouble
it's going to be the chase no no they're
gonna stop good dissidents but very low
mana Gordon Uzi or actually still trying
to taste this
that means oozing it's hot he tries to
jump in for the kill
that's not going to be what he wanted
more kills coming up for Juicy
but EDG rallied brought it to game four
and eventually to a pivotal fifth game
Guzzi was still a young player he might
have built up a respectable amount of
domestic experience he might have played
in a World Finals but in many ways he
still lacked experience and as EDG began
to mount a shocking comeback whose
mentality began to decline can history
repeat itself for easy there's so much
pressure on him youngsters Himanshu job
is hey yo yo yo machine hey Romeo
no more horoho Johanna nany Toro
Shana enjoy tiger palaces poly pillars
and we'll play on the with her and then
tiny helped in an idea to me oh man I
never think of it as the primary carry
for his team there was a lot of pressure
on easy to perform and even with a
couple years of pro experience under his
belt Busey was still a 17 year old kid
but feeling the match slipping away
Susie's team rallied behind him so far
his time alone playing in his favor what
chord chart and houthi picks up freeze
Suzie
Luzi semi-final opponents another
Chinese team in oMG were likewise a
major roadblock
but in the end Boyle made it to the
finals
but in front of a boisterous home crowd
it was Korea's Samsung white and not
royal that itched their names into
league history
[Music]
just what an extraordinary World
Championship Samsung white has had her
royal club they get their first single
victory in a World Championship final
but it's not enough to take down the
mobsters that are Samsung white it was
another year that saw Ozzy distinguished
himself against a host of international
and domestic opponents another year
where he came up short it was time for
something new in December rival Chinese
team OMG acquired Ozzy in what is
probably the biggest roster move the LPL
has ever seen it was a new team and a
new infrastructure for Ozzy who had
never played for an org other than royal
and the team had some initial trouble
meshing Oh Jeanette oMG to be openly
when a contender in the tariff or OGC :
America show Jemima shape - is jong-un
or come :
Lorelei's modular from dora-chan school
booyah emoji ginge call the raw star
power on this new team was enough for
them to have a reasonable regular season
in spring 2015 but a disappointing exit
in playoff quarterfinals was far less
than many fans expected of the region's
top ADC they're not stopping they're
looking to try and end the game they
trying to end the series Atlas they go
in there looking for a cool get gets
destroy that is ridiculous God be so
good on this Kassadin hecarim does take
down flame but these Nexus cards now
falling down in doing so much damage
oMG get a stand lose the game instantly
29 minutes LGD this is the quickest one
yet 3-0 - oMG absolutely speechless
because oMG are a world-class lineup but
they were outclassed in most positions
the entirety of that cereal things
didn't get much better in the summer
splay as oMG headed toward a seventh
place finish in the regular season
woozi found himself once again
struggling to constructively handle his
frustrations
whadda ya mean I should tell you well to
incentive for translation your chocolate
has you on city domain off a beautiful
whammy would use another yarn in a while
you universes read lights the curtain
[Music]
and this time there would be no world's
birth no big stage no chance at
redemption at the end of 2015
Newsies place in the League of Legends
landscape was still somewhat uncertain
he'd cemented himself as one of the
biggest stars in the most populous
region for the game and it was
impossible to deny his skills but three
years into his career Busey had yet to
win a title at any level
he was a king without a crown he knew
who he was and what a what a man used to
say when the wall actually instantly got
control of entrance Angela what angle
should be autonomous which i think is
obviously another moon huh
[Music]
in December Susie made another move
joining the xiaogu Reapers and the
beginning of the spring split looked
good for his new team you know try and
turn things around the base is just
breaking in every spot and Uzi it's free
firing away from the sidelines
they might even dive the fountain to
finish things often qg1 teamfight later
they'll break the base and go undefeated
this is all over Joker on in the face of
IT and only splitting the team they
could have better take them down one by
one they get the ace and choker look to
destroy the Nexus and get the reverse
sweep against it Victor's game Jeep
looks strong ruin his glorious kDa to
dive the fountain again the last kill
[Music]
it's back here and despite some
challenges in the latter half of the
split
Shaggy's dominant start was enough for
first in their group and up by two
play-off semi-finals but their playoff
run did not go well Shaggy's roster was
grappling with personnel issues and in a
somewhat shocking example of them they
went into semi finals without a mid
laner despite having four signed to the
orc can I have to see what happens here
but unfortunately that is a surprise we
just got an announce one for CH initely
chuggers mid laner cannot be here for
today's match third they're gonna have
to forfeit this muster five series that
is a big surprise coming for the lineup
EDG win this match 3-0 though they were
able to feel the mid laner in the third
place match world elite swept xiaogu 3o
putting an end to their season Busey had
played with some incredible players
since you've left royal but he'd been
unable to find much success it was time
for the stray dog to come home
back on RNG Busey was home and the new
roster rampaged through the summer split
laning them directly in semi-finals
there they defeated I may in a close 3-2
series it was another chance of the
finals another hope for a title but RNG
weren't up for the task and EDG trounced
them by one they take tower Lucas
guardian angel la cheese is down as well
Lucy's lockdown please can destroy clean
up picks up the kill anology
they get an HD by a DJ that's it EDG
will reclaim their throne as the premier
team in the LPL and again boothy is
denied another LPL title it was another
split without a domestic title but
Royals performance throughout 2016
qualified them for worlds on
championship points in the end royal
made it out of groups but their run at
Worlds was cut short
yet again coming up on the river rewsey
cancelled his recall flashes available
it seeping get away the answer does not
seem to be so who's he goes first lots
of follow shortly and that is where
everything falls apart for RNG back to
mid lane Shou who's killed not time yet
fangs looking for easy
[Applause]
bang gets out of line this is gonna get
messy Scott one two looking for a third
not gonna be enough because fakers got
himself a double Matta throws up the RNG
flag but it's a dying flag royal or ace
the Nexus is down the turret will fall
shortly
SK Telecom advance to the semi-final at
Worlds it was the second time SKT had
eliminated royal from worlds and though
this time it was 3-1 royal were
outclassed in 2017 it seemed like royal
was doomed to repeat the same story
lines they placed first in the regular
season into both spring and summer but
lost in the finals both times and worlds
that year was more of the same once
again royal made it out of groups and
their quarterfinal performance against
fnatic was likewise compelling and
heading into their semi-final match
against once again SKT there was hope
for royal fans SKT were not playing the
way they had in years past and it looked
like they had weaknesses royal might be
able to expose the series was close
wagons life the plush foreign currency
[Applause]
perfect register let me and Uzi is here
the wolf is gonna be falling Oh see but
royal still couldn't overcome as Katie
the 2018 spring regular season looks
strong for Royal never give up but
heading into playoffs all eyes in the
region were on the team that placed
first in their group Invictus gaming
dominated the regular season with an 18
one record and fielded a rising talent
named the shy who was being widely
heralded as perhaps the best top laner
in the world with IG seated directly
into the semi-finals and RNG working
their way through the bracket the
thought of an RNG versus IG semi-final
was tantalizing but it didn't quite
happen that way IG and orangey faced off
but the shiz dynamic carry potential was
not a factor as he was sidelined in
playoffs by an injury royal took that
series 3 to 2 and with perhaps their
greatest obstacle out of the way
momentum was on their side heading into
the grand finals momentum that Uzi and
his teammates would not put to waste
Freya's assassinated me still looking to
threaten this one to tie forth the flash
away bruising
that dog is mocking to get to kill for
himself ray the assassinating all of
Baker's paw patrols are all and they
turn out to vote Ghana to tie as heat
race shown the finest vote but EDG that
retreat because of lightning it's being
slammed down from the ragnarok of all of
us about continued night in an hour GE
classes was the pinnacle be a 50/50 on
or comes out clean he's almost in the
black one barrage a for the T foot
these points declarant he thinks the way
from a DJ order there let me want it now
scout using the same sense that he's
gonna go down as well
Ruthy picks up a double and there's only
one member left that's right only to do
now is dot the i's cross the t's aren t
they have set themselves up to win where
were you with the curse lifted the
prophecy is being fulfilled
who's he now
[Applause]
finally for the first time ever the
LPL's greatest ad carry hoisted a trophy
for the first time ever
Cousy was a champion who is he's a
really interesting player because prior
to this year everyone always said he was
the best player to never win anything it
used to be before that Uzi was kind of
this mad dog on a leash and his team
just kind of held the leash back this
time around he's more of the leading
sled dog you know charging forward to
victory and really paving the path for
ng with his first domestic title under
his belt Busey made his way to msi for
the first time in his career hopes were
high for the LPL superstars but they
would have to contend with a king's own
dragon axe that had looked utterly
dominant in the springs boy but in
groups King's Own seemed less than
untouchable they finished in third while
royal and the flash wolves topped the
leaderboard
Korea rebounded the semis though as both
King zone and royal made quick work of
their semi-final opponents and so it all
came down to the finals hello and
welcome to the conclusion of MSI 2018 as
orangy ready to reclaim the MSI
championship trophy for the LPL as they
look to take down korea's king's own
dragon axe
ladies and gentlemen in Paris and around
the world let's keep up the fight for
the championship and the title royal got
ahead despite King zones explosive power
as a team but heading into a do-or-die
game for the Koreans drafted a
composition with terrifying teamfight
combo potential three items spikes by
the way inside of RNG
one misstep away from a game five he
knew he had to do and he made inside the
cheeps
are agli and it didn't have there
[Music]
ja who is on his way boy
[Music]
[Applause]
Cousy had done it King's Own did what so
many teams had done before they drafted
CC and team fighting to burst Uzi down
to negate Royals lethal carry but it
didn't matter with his back against the
wall with match point in his hands Susie
brought it home he put the team on his
back and he conquered
[Applause]
now reads the world
the summer split was another split of
domestic success for Royal never give up
this time the fated rematch against
Invictus gaming came in the grand finals
[Applause]
and so in a year that also saw royal
take wins at the Asia Games and at rift
rivals Guzzi entered the 2018 World
Championship in an unusual position
whose East are already burning so
brightly in Chinese league had only
risen in 2018 riot had commemorated him
in their music video for worlds and even
Nike had recognized him as the face of
Chinese game in this has been the year
of RNG right there yeah title after
title after title and their next stop
you know is the World Championship but
they're gonna have to go through the
defending champions in the group stage
you know if they want to get that
number1 seed and have a better spot RNG
many people's favorites for the World
Championship I think along with KT and
then you look at every single pool to
team that could possibly be with RNG you
would have to say Genji or freaka freaks
are the hardest one but in 2018 Worlds
was different it had been a year of
subverted expectations though Ozzy was
never really in danger of not making it
out of groups their path out as the
first seed came down to a white-knuckle
tiebreaker against a surging cloud 9 but
they will come out of the group of death
as the first seed they will shatter
cloud nines base they will await their
quarterfinal opponents it is obtuse asel
the defend against the
and it will not happen RNG will make it
true and they will take the seed boils
quarterfinal opponents were g2 eSports
but Royals victory felt inevitable it
seemed a foregone conclusion that royal
would face off against Katie in the
semi-finals
the tournament's two favorites clashing
for a spot in the finals but things did
not work out that way
five games this loop might just be
anchors coming in let's see whether
nothing can find the kill there's this
tunnel to Izzy's body boy kick it award
Busey can't pick it up he's going to go
down jail Susie's turning it back around
defensive flash from Uzi tell him what's
coming down find out we've delivered a
perfect
Luzi had been chasing a world title
since that first time he sat across from
SK Telecom team one since that first
time is slipped through his fingers and
this year in Korea it seemed like his
year like his chance to seize his
destiny instead a different LPL team
hoisted the summoner's Cup it was a
disappointing loss for RNG and firuze II
but 2018 isn't like 2013 or 2014 it's
not like the years soozee struggled to
find domestic success to trust his
teammates to take home championships
because this year hoozy returned to
China a winner
sure he went home from worlds of
battered but you can't take the rest of
2018 away from him Busey has faced all
the highs and lows competitive league
has to offer he's seen the biggest
stages
heard the roar of the loudest crowds
he's been the playmaker before my layoff
and the troublemaker but through it all
he's grown into something far greater
than the kid with incredible vein
mechanics who first dazzled the world
and when the book closes on his career
he won't be remembered as the greatest
player to never win a title but he may
just be remembered as the greatest
player period thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button